kylie jenner had a quite the adventure  is a thursday at new york fashion week  my worst nightmare just happened  we are stuck in the elevator yes highly  her sister Kendall and pals at Jordan  woods and hailey Baldwin got trapped in  this door open  huh  but i think this is what's holding no no  it's not all only food we don't know i'm  going to be in here but all the food we  had an elementary ate it all  hi fire department  Jordan to that the girls were eventually  rescued but before that Charlie gave us  an outfit of the day this is my outfit  Kylie actually showed off multiple  outfits during the day there was also  this shimmery look I am really getting  my hair think it's gonna stay for a  minute just faded maroon jacket  another key and then this denim number  she wore out with Tyga that's also when  Kylie shut off this massive a diamond  ring  she captioned the video if this is a  promise ring  I want to know what my engagement ring  gonna look like